what do you think the purpose of
this human existence is
man
that is an excellent question i think
that is something that i grapple with
truly every
day i think that's been like the biggest
challenge for me is finding
meaning in all of this
um but i guess i guess the purpose
to me um or like what i've decided it is
is like you know we have
moments in life um big and small and
it's just about applying
meaning to it whatever that is
to you i think um because i mean
sometimes i think like is there any
meaning at all like maybe we're just
here to be here and that's it but i
guess it's like it's about what meaning
you apply to it you know and maybe what
you can leave
behind and finding some sort of
permanence in the impermanence um
because you know the idea of of uh
impermanence is very scary to me it's
something that i've always been so like
fearful of the idea of like fleeting
life and
um the fact that everything you do here
can just like be gone you know so i
guess it's just about applying meaning
to it wow okay
well i'm gonna cut to the chase so that
you understand why i asked such a sort
of big question but i also think
something that you said right there was
very interesting too um that i want to
ask a question about but the purpose is
because whenever i've been asked that
question or whenever i've asked myself
that question
the answer i come up with or i have come
up with years ago was that i think that
the purpose of this existence is to
experience duality
and
i know that that's the theme of your
album
so i was very curious to hear what you
thought and then for you to just talk
about what duality then i guess what
does duality mean to you that's a theme
why is why why did that come up
for you
yeah well i think it was for a few
different reasons or in a few different
ways i think first off
um there's kind of a through line or a
thread on this project will where it
feels sort of like a point a and a point
b like the beginning of the album is
you know my mindset in the place that i
was in you know in the first half of the
year and then as the the songs you know
go on and as you know the story
progresses um there's like a point b is
sort of where i ended up and where i
kind of am now
um you know on the second half of that
year and the second half of the the
writing process but also again like this
year was er in last year was like super
challenging for me in many ways i was
faced with like um
i guess like death for the first time
somebody really close to me got very ill
and i think that's when i started
thinking a lot about the meaning of
existence and life and death and i you
know just like realized that like
nothing and everything matters at the
exact same time and you know and that's
kind of like where the whole idea of
duality came in and i realized how
important it kind of is and how
prominent it is in life you know like we
are made up of duality and like
it's kind of like i don't know like
there's like two sides to one coin in
life you know and like nothing matters
but at the same time everything matters
in a way and i still don't even
like quite understand what that exactly
means or how to navigate that but that's
just kind of the conclusion i've come to
and um yeah just duality has been
extremely present in my in my life but
also in my writing process and like
looking at pain from two different ways
and just looking at life in general from
two different ways whenever i experience
something and for some reason it usually
has to be negative but when i experience
something really hard and difficult and
negative and my last year was a
total evolution and growth period for
for me as well and so i'm curious and
we've talked about it being like coming
this album comes on the heels of so much
growth and so much a hard time
but when i experience the negative it
gives me pers it gives me the positive
equal and opposite like i can i
experience so much pain and sadness but
i was able to then experience this very
simple blissful joy
in a really like basic moment of looking
at a tree
so
it's like such a bummer
but it's like to get the pleasure you
have to experience the pain but i feel
like duality for me kind of expanded and
once it once one expanded i realized
that there was an equal and opposite
sort of reaction on the other side and
what i ended up realizing
through that experience of enough times
of that negative through different
things whether it be the ways ways that
i felt something that i was thinking
all kinds of stuff is that i was like
holy [ __ ] i'm like it's part of the same
hole
which then
leads to oneness
and i was like wow they feel like you
know duality to me felt like bad and
good you know but what i realized is
that it's all part of the same whole 100
yeah it's like one can't necessarily
exist without the other you can't really
like
look at one thing the same way without
the other i know for me like i hit some
of you know the heaviest rock bottoms in
the last couple years and like you know
when you're so not okay like
you hold on to the moments where you are
okay so much more even if they're like
like you said like little mundane simple
basic moments that you wouldn't have you
know looked twice at before
suddenly are just so much more
important to you you know when you when
you experience the other end of that
duality of like you know just feeling so
not okay and not seeing any light at all
that when you do find any glimmer of
light again it's like applying more
meaning to it like the same things can
happen to us but at different times in
our lives they mean such different
things just because of perspective you
know you just realize how much
it life really is about perspective
it's
all perspective essentially i i mean i
think i think you've nailed it it's
it's what meaning we attach to something
it's how we decide to see it it's like i
remember when i was having my saddest of
times i like loved going out and walking
in the woods in nature and
have my dogs with me and my mom and you
know and she would be out walking and
she'd be like man it's such a beautiful
day and i didn't notice it at all like i
couldn't even notice how beautiful the
day was
at all um so what were the
if you're willing to share what were the
things that kind of put you in that
put that put you in that space was it
professional was it personal was it
lost like what what got you there
um it was i think a collection of
different things i think you know a big
chunk of it was um
just suppressing a lot of
feelings um that i
you know thought i had gotten over but i
was actually just pushing down over the
last seven years in my career i think
this very fast-paced lifestyle doesn't
really allow you to process emotions or
process things in a normal
way
um and so i just thought like oh wow
like you know i can just get over things
and i'm strong and whatever but what i
thought was actually being strong or
what i thought was healing was actually
just complete suppression and throwing
under the rug
um and it wasn't until i had like you
know a complete halt in life until we
all experienced that halt and that like
complete lack of distraction where i
like
everything just sort of boiled over but
then also you know experiencing somebody
really close to me being so close to
death and
um i mean i've always had like a weird
phobia of death but it wasn't until
that i was like faced with that and like
was so close to it for the first time
that i really went into this spiral of
like okay what is the meaning of life i
mean i attach so much
meaning so much of my identity to my job
and what i do for a living you know and
again so when i didn't have that when i
didn't have that distraction i was just
like well okay who am i what's the point
of anything
you know how can all these good people
just go
you know and then what happens to us
after like i was just in a complete
spiral of thought and fear and my phobia
turned into like full blown panic attack
and
panic disorder and um
you know i just i was just like
completely
just off the rails it felt like yeah
yeah i just completely spiraled um so
yeah it was like it was a collection of
different things a lot of suppressing a
lot of like
going down rabbit holes of thought with
no answer because obviously like you
know there is no real answer to what is
the meaning of life and what happens
after we die so it's not just fun to
talk about
yeah so there's no way that i could like
talk myself down in a logical way and so
i i lost like the color to life because
i was like well nothing matters and like
you were saying sorry to go on a tangent
but i love it
that's what i'm asking for cool um well
yeah you touched on a good point where
like you know you would go on walks and
your mom would be like oh like what a
beautiful day i remember like people
would say that all the time
and like in a cerebral logical rational
way i knew like the right answer would
be like yeah it is right that's the
thing you say like yeah i guess it's a
nice day but i wouldn't actually really
feel it or see it i would just like
respond because that's what you do you
say yeah it is or whatever you know
right and it wasn't until like i really
really like did the proper healing and
like went to like
therapy and just really like hashed a
lot of things out with myself that i was
able to actually like enjoy and for the
first time the last few months i've been
able to like walk outside and like think
to myself like it is a nice day like
this is what people were seeing like the
blinders are kind of off um and it's not
like a black and white thing of course
it's not like suddenly the veil has been
lifted and life is amazing but you know
it's definitely a cyclical thing and i
have days where you know that feel a
little bit grayer still but i'm able to
have those moments now where i
understand
like what people are talking about about
it being a nice day or like enjoying and
appreciating moments you know